bonsoir jackass miss merci avec mon
direct sur rt france du clientélisme
indigéniste selon christophe castaner
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
appellation
la première chose à dire sur cette
affaire c'est que on a l'impression que
toute la classe politique et la classe
médiatique aussi d'ailleurs se
rencontrent juste maintenant de l'islamo
gauchisme du racialisme delà du racisme
anti-blanc de ce syndicat toutes ces
choses que je viens d'énumérer lui ni
nous on ne dénonce en fait depuis des
années on combat sur le terrain depuis
plus de plus de 50 ans et donc on se
demande en fait pourquoi il suffit d'une
dune d'une interview à europe 1 pour que
tout le monde s'excite sur ce sujet
encore une fois nous ça fait des années
que cet islam au gauchisme ce raciste
anti-blanc ses dérives ses gratte
ségrégationniste on les dénonce
et qu'il faut et qu'il faut les
combattre donc aujourd'hui il est clair
que cette année on est dans cette
surprise de voir toute cette classe
politique se faire un peu leur leur coup
de buzz et leurs coups de com sur 7 sur
cette affaire il faut il faut clairement
maintenant soutenir lui ni sur sur tous
les combats que l'on fait depuis des
années
alors vous dites ça fait des années mais
enfin des des réunions excluant les
blancs c'est quelque chose qui dure
depuis des années vous vous l'audit où
c'est un phénomène tout de même récents
et vous savez les délires de l'unef les
dérives racialiste les dérives des
colonialistes les dérives du racisme
anti blanc à l'unef
ça fait effectivement des années que ça
commence que ça a commencé par don très
récemment on a eu comme vous le savez la
sphère de grenoble ou l'unef grenoble a
volontairement afficher le nom de deux
professeurs et a appelé au lynchage de
ses professeurs il y a bien évidemment
les camps des coloniaux qui sont
organisées par ce syndicat des coloniaux
ou des tests des colonialistes l'était
indigéniste sont sont clairement
affichées il y a des listes communes
avec les étudiants musulmans de france
qui ont déjà approuvé moult fois leur
leurs accointances avec l'islamisme
radical
il y à des réactions de nombreux des
responsables nationaux et locaux
d'ailleurs de lunettes
après l'émoi qu'a publicité le lincendie
de notre dame de paris où je cite les
mois que susciter cette cet incendie
était qualifié de délire de petits
blancs par des responsables de l'unef
donc vous savez la dérive de l'unef
aujourd'hui eh bien ça fait des années
qu'on la dénonce et il faut bien se
rendre compte que l'unef n'est
aujourd'hui plus du tout représentatif
du monde étudiant et on se donne on se
demande encore une fois pourquoi le
ministère pense encore aujourd'hui
qu'ils peuvent s'appuyer sur une
organisation comme l'unef pour
représenter les étudiants et donc j'y
viens aux subventions publiques on se
demande comment le ministère peut encore
donner des centaines de milliers d'euros
par an à une organisation qui a prouvé
qu'il le prouve aujourd'hui encore qu'il
qu'ils affichent tout simplement tout
les toutes les valeurs anti france
aujourd'hui clairement certains
demandent qu'on poursuive en justice la
présidente de l'unef vous est-ce que
c'est prendre le problème par le bon
bout est ce que c'est c'est comme ça
justement qu'on va faire taire ce
phénomène aujourd'hui ce que l'uni
demande demande ces deux choses
principales premièrement c'est tout
simplement l'arrêt immédiat des
subventions publiques à cette
organisation encore une fois anti france
à cette organisation racialiste et à
cette organisation qui n'est plus du
tout dans les valeurs qui font notre
pays et les valeurs qui fondent occident
et puis deuxièmement c'est aussi vous
vous souvenez frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur qui a demandé
une une enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme
on s'était bien évidemment réjoui
qu'elle utilise ce terme puisque c'est
une réalité contrairement à ce que dit
le cnrs contre ce contrairement à ce que
dit la conférence des présidents
d'université qui sont tous eux-mêmes
gangréné par cette idéologie de l'islamo
gauchisme et bien on demande aux
personnes ça que ce ne soit plus des
mots mais des actes et donc qu'il y ait
une enquête indépendante sur ces
recherches sur l'intersexualité sur le
racialisme sort encore une fois tout ce
qui fait la haine anti blanc est donc
aujourd'hui c'est l'arrêt immédiat des
subventions publiques à cette
organisation anti france qui prône
clairement le racisme anti blanc et une
accointance et la promotion tout
simplement d'un islam politique
et puis deux
aimant une enquête aussi sur toutes ces
recherches qui prouve en fait un gant
grainage du monde de l'université que ça
soit bien évidemment dans le
syndicalisme étudiant mais aussi aux
plus hautes sphères
quand je vous ai dit les conférence de
présidents d'université et le cnrs
lui-même est gangréné en son sein par
une part par cette idéologie donc
aujourd'hui encore une fois quand on
voit la classe politico-médiatique qui
se réveille et bien on leur demande tout
simplement de se rendre compte que nos
élus ni ça fait des années ça fait plus
de cinquante ans qu'on existe a fait
plus de 50 ans sur les terrains on
combat cette organisation et ça fait des
années que ces réunions non mixtes où
les blancs ou les où les hommes sont
interdites
on les combat aussi et qu'il faut
maintenant soutenir lui ni lui ni est le
fer de lance de l'opposition à l'unef
lui n'y est le fer de lance de
l'opposition à toutes ces idéologies
mortifère qui gangrène nos universités
et qu'il faut soutenir notre combat
maintenant très clairement
merci jacques ruiz d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france